a t planched by T-Mobile USA and a 39
billion dollar deal that would make it
the largest cell phone company in the
U.S it was virtually a dead brand it had
very low brand awareness we are going to
redefine a
broken
arrogant industry
[Music]
virtually everybody in the entire world
knows that jingle for many of us that
ringtone is not just reminiscent of his
own company but an entire time period
the early 2000s a time before
smartphones and smart watches and smart
Everything Computers and cell phones
were just starting to gain popularity
amongst the general public and ringtones
were a fashion statement not something
that you would apologize for
thank you
but a smartphones became more mainstream
the popularity of ringtones fell off a
cliff and with it when the popularity of
T-Mobile this trend was only made worse
by the 2008 financial recession which
caused the stock to sell off 86 things
got so bad that T-Mobile even agreed to
being bought out by atnt for 39 billion
dollars in 2011. but that deal was
stopped by the US government with
nowhere left to go T-Mobile just
continued its death dive and during the
worst of it T-Mobile was writing off
everything they had leading to losses of
over seven and a half billion dollars
per year at this point you would think
that it was just a matter of time until
T-Mobile filed for bankruptcy but then
came a new CEO John Ledger hopes weren't
that high given that Jon didn't not have
much to work with but somehow over the
next eight years Jon would stage out one
of the biggest comebacks of corporate
history since then T-Mobile has grown a
mind-boggling Nineteen Hundred percent
or 20x and they have transitioned from
being the ones who needed a bailout to
being the ones handing out bailouts
likely the best example of this is their
merger or basically acquisition of
Sprint which propelled them to not only
be a telecom Juggernaut but be the
largest Telecom company in the entire
world period they currently stand at a
valuation of
186 billion dollars and fun fact the
recession hasn't affected their stock
price whatsoever they're literally
floating around all-time highs as we
speak so here's how T-Mobile went from
being so popular that they were a symbol
of a time period to near bankruptcy to
becoming the largest Telecom company in
the world
foreign
doesn't actually start in America it
actually starts in Germany and to this
day the original T-Mobile or Deutsche
Telecom is still a German Giant in fact
there are D6 the largest Telecom company
in the world ended they trace their
Roots all the way back to 1866 to
Germany's national Postal Service
reich's post while the organization was
technically a meal service they were
really more of a Communications business
so after the invention of telephones Rex
post was one of the first to adopt the
technology and spread it across the
country but the real rise of our exposed
did not come to the rise of Mr small
mustache in the 1930s and 40s Mr small
mustache was well aware of it just how
critical robust communication was and
trying to challenge the world powers so
he spent a lot of resources to build an
upright's post and before Germany
started losing reich's post was stronger
than ever for obvious reasons the Allied
Forces weren't exactly fans of this and
after they took over they would shut
down Rex Post in 1947. they would split
up the organization into a few smaller
organizations the most notable of which
were Deutsche bundesposed in West
Germany and at Deutsche Post in East
Germany these two organizations would
essentially remain as state-owned
monopolies up until the fall of the
Berlin Wall just a couple of months
before the collapse West Germany would
split the Deutsche bundespost into three
sectors which included a postal service
a postal bank and of course a
Communication Service after the fall of
the Berlin Wall these sectors were
basically absorb the remains of the East
German services and given that
capitalism was now the prevailing idea
across the country Germany would
eventually decide to spin off these
sectors into public companies at the
beginning of 1995 leading to the
creation of Deutsche Telecom around the
same time an American Wireless
Communications company called Western
Wireless was starting to gain a lot of
traction Western Wireless was founded in
1988 and they were an early mover when
it came to wireless technology I mean
Wireless is literally in their name
given that Western Wireless they did not
have the infrastructure to compete
against at T in the traditional
telephone Market they spent all of their
effort on the wireless market and more
specifically the rural Wireless Market
which was regularly overlooked by the
large providers it turns out that this
was actually a super lucrative and the
Western Wireless would eventually grow
to compete in even non-rural areas in
the meantime given that Deutsche Telecom
was now a corporate entity focused on
profits they would shift their focus
onto aggressive expansion they expanded
to basically every European country you
can think of from Austria and Croatia to
Slovakia and the UK but for the purposes
of this video we'll focus on their
expansion to the US this came in 2000
with the purchase of a subsidiary of
Western Wireless called voice stream
Wireless for a ridiculous
50.7 billion dollars fortunately they
would negotiate this down to 30 billion
but voice dreamo wasn't worth anywhere
near 30 billion either Deutsche Telecom
bought the absolute top of the.com
bubble and when the crash came around
their stock would fall 90 and never
recover but on the bright side they now
owned what we all know as T-Mobile
while Deutsche Telecom likely overpaid
for a voice stream by a full 10x it
wasn't all bad news at the end of the
day voice dream was still growing
rapidly and at Georgia Telecom had a
bunch of money in that they could throw
at voice stream to try to win the US
market in the early 2000s this worked
out great and this is why we all
remember the T-Mobile jinglewood took
this day but T-Mobile had one major
weakness which is that they weren't
actually doing anything particularly
noteworthy or Innovative they were
basically just riding their wave of
Wireless adoption and while this worked
out decently while the market was still
exponentially growing the same could it
not be said about the mature Market you
see it once the core factor of having a
cell phone wore off people actually
started to Value the quality of the
connection and let's just say the
quality of T-Mobile was absolute garbage
while this made customers quite mad and
irritated it wasn't enough to kill Timo
double altogether something that was
enough to kill T-Mobile though was a TNT
at T had been watching this whole Saga
from the sidelines for the entirety of
the 1900s they were the Undisputed king
of Telecom even government mandated
breakups could not destroy their power
but now all of a sudden it some rural
wireless network owned by some Deutsche
company overseas was threatening at
atd's dominance in their home country
this was unacceptable and ATT was
determined for T-Mobile back in their
place but to do this atnt had to make
big bets simply offering better service
wasn't good enough so they looked back
at their history and analyzed how they
got so big in the first place and the
answer was that they were an unbreakable
Monopoly what they had to do was
recreate this Monopoly and the perfect
opportunity to do this came with the
iPhone Apple wasn't exactly an easy
company to work with but ATT was willing
to do whatever it took this included
giving Apple full control of the
software paying out Apple for every
iPhone that was sold and probably dozens
of other Clauses as well but in return
Apple granted ATT with exclusive rights
to the iPhone meaning that if you wanted
to buy an iPhone in the US you had to
buy it with an ATT connection this
didn't seem like a big deal given that
no one really knew how big the iPhone
would get but looking back this was
likely att's best choice of the century
as they were able to rebuild their
Monopoly for nearly 4 years it wasn't
until 2011 that Verizon would get their
hands on the iPhone and Sprint would
also partner with apple later that year
back in Germany Deutsche Telecom had
struck a similar exclusivity deal with
Apple like atnt but as for T-Mobile us
well they were screwed they would
essentially seek out a bailout from atnt
but as we touched on at the beginning
the government would block that from
it seemed like T-Mobile was gonna share
the same fate as most of its.com peers
in a last-ditch effort the company would
hire a new CEO named John Ledger and a
man this guy would do the impossible
John wasn't your typical CEO in fact he
was the exact opposite and he wasn't
afraid to admit that either the first
thing he noticed after he took over was
the overly diplomatic nature of the
Telecom industry everything was so
uptight pristine and closely monitored
this was the way that ATT and the
Verizon light did and so everyone
followed suit but this strategy clearly
wasn't working for T-Mobile not to
mention T-Mobile had none of the
pristine advantages that at T or Verizon
had they didn't have a deal with Apple
they didn't have a massive marketing
budget and they didn't even have a
strong Network in fact they had a
notably crappy network but despite this
T-Mobile was trying to act like an equal
peer to ATT and Verizon so Jon decided
to take the opposite approach instead of
trying to hide who they were John
embraced it he realized that people were
fed up with atn's predatory cell phone
contracts with low towards a fine print
into dozens of hidden fees so he made
T-Mobile deal on Carrier and the first
I've been doing this was calling up
Apple John didn't ask Apple to give them
a juicy deal in fact he asked for the
opposite he asked if they could sell the
iPhone for MSRP given that this didn't
seem threatening to a TNT or Verizon
Apple had an easy time agreeing with
this and with that T-Mobile finally got
the iPhone in 2013 and they embraced who
they were yeah they were crappy they
were cheap and yes having a T-Mobile
connection would probably hurt your
social status but guess what they're not
gonna overcharge you or screw you over
with the fine print there was also
absolutely no contracts or cancellation
fees and for tens of millions of
Americans who had been screwed over by
atnt and Verizon for decades this is
exactly what they wanted but this did
not mean that people switched over
instantly in fact it was a rather slow
burner because people didn't quite trust
T-Mobile I mean there's no way that a
carrier was actually acting decent and
reasonable right that breaks the laws of
physics so where's the catch well there
actually was no catch but the general
public only started to believe this once
they're daring friends and family
confirmed that there was no catch this
strategy did destroy all of T-Mobile's
margins as they lost out on all of the
predatory Revenue agent for example
generally has net margins of 10 percent
meanwhile T-Mobile was barely able to
crack net margins of two to four percent
but something that T-Mobile had that no
one else did was happy customers and it
is translated to exponential growth in
the last 10 years T-Mobile's annual
revenue has rocketed from 5 billion
dollars per year to 80 billion dollars
per year and today T-Mobile has a total
of 110 million Wireless subscribers
fibers which is about a third of the US
population making them the world's
largest Telecom company
while T-Mobile has maintained their
generous customer policies they haven't
been as stubborn when it comes to
maintaining their crappy quality instead
they've invested much of their extra
Revenue back into growing their
infrastructure and making the service
better and today they're actually the
leader when it comes to 5G service
According to some research done by open
signal the average 5G download speed for
T-Mobile was 150 Mbps this was three
times higher than an ATT and Verizon who
scored about 50 Mbps and speaking from
personal experience 150 Mbps is actually
the low side when it comes to T-Mobile's
5G speeds if you live in popular suburbs
or urban areas you can expect much
faster speeds for example I live in
Austin Texas and I regularly get
download speeds above 600 Mbps I mean
that's literally Fiber speeds right
there so clearly T-Mobile is no longer
just killing it in the affordability
sector they're also killing it in the
performance sector as well and that's
how T-Mobile went from being a legacy
German company who tried to win using
their power and influence to being the
underdog favorite to being the global
Champion it looks like doing the right
thing it does end up paying off from
time to time do you like your career
comment that down below also drop a like
if you wish that all carriers were as
decent as T-Mobile and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community suggest future video ideas and
to consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Harriet and I'll see you guys
on the next one